[Musique]
ce mercredi 7 février le département a
organisait la 5e édition des Rencontres
départementale de la commande publique
dans la salle polyvalente du champ- de
foire de brapanon une quarantaine de
chefs d'entreprise prestataires et
artisant ont répondu à l'invitation et
sont venus s'informer sur les procédures
à suivre pour répondre au marché public
lancé par la collectivité en compagnie
du maire de brapanon et vice-président
du département Jan Chapa le président
Cyril Melchor est venu à à la rencontre
des participants nous en sommes à peu
près 1800
attributions en c'est en progression
parce que avant la crise covid le
département investissait à peu près 130
millions d'euros aujourd'hui on approche
les 200 millions et c'est un c'est une
volonté politique que nous exprimons là
parce que nous quand il y a eu C crise
covid on a vu que les entreprise ont
beaucoup souffert bah du manque
d'activité tout simplement et pour
éviter ben les l'affaiblissement du
tissu économique réonnais le département
fait le choix d'investir introduction de
clauses d'insertion pour favoriser
l'inclusion de demandeurs d'emploi
amélioration des conditions de paiement
priorité à l'économie circulaire et au
circuit court de nombreuses initiatives
ont été prises depuis le début de la
mandature pour améliorer les procédures
de la commande publique notre but c'est
de faire appel au maximum d'entreprises
de pouvoir par le mode d'allotissement
favoriser aussi l'attribution des
marchés à un maximum d'entreprises pour
que de l'activité le département puisse
en donner au plus grand nombre des
entreprises de la cette 5e édition ne
sera pas la dernière les rencontres
départementales de la commande publique
sont organisées dans toutes les
microégion de
[Musique]
lîle